hey everybody welcome to this new
episode of roller coaster cone 3 which
is actually not that new because as you
might have actually noticed i skipped
one time lapse that I record it so yeah
welcome to my life I always forget [ __ ]
and this is one of the things that I
forgot and also something else that I
forgot and I got so many comments on
this where as soon as I release the
video held that was even now I'll still
even posted as some green text message
on skype saying be silver at build a
wing rider make a tunnel that doesn't
even fit the wing ride it I was like yep
that's me because yeah I did actually
built that tunnel and that tunnel didn't
fit the wing rider at all and oh by the
way I need to turn on my son I'm
blasting Soulja Boy into my ears I don't
want that but yeah I kind of forgot that
I was building a wing ryder while
building it so yeah that's me hi I'm
silver i think i forget what I'm
building while I'm building it so now
I've got two things that I can do I can
either remove that tunnel which is
something that I would not like to do
because I kind of like it and there's
one laser your option that I might
actually turn out to be something better
in the future but I don't know quite
what i'm going to do but that second
option is to actually not make it a wing
right it i mean i am going to get rid of
that CTR in regardless of why do because
it's a it's a little [ __ ] ugly CTR
it's not like i'm actually going to use
that thing it's it's the worst thing
ever i don't know if i can actually find
a good furious barco cgi I swear I need
I need to I need to force myself not to
say furious taco because if I don't do
that it's gonna get it's gonna go wrong
at some point in time but yeah I kind of
want to get either CTR of that but I no
no that's actually there and i don't
know if i'll actually be content with
that so what I actually want to try and
what's its kind of something that may
even fit the layout that I made more
than a wing rider it's just making an in
terment blitz or whatever you guys call
those things these days like I can't I
can't keep up with all of that but it's
kind of like Cheetah Hunt and to be very
honest I also had an idea of Cheetah
Hunt in mind while building that roller
coaster so I might always just get rid
of the entire wing rider idea and just
turn it into something else I guess I
might
decide for myself what I'm going to do
but if you really want to leave your
opinion on it if you really want that
wing rider to say you can always say
that of course I mean I might listen to
people not because of love but because I
always fall for those and for the peer
pressured so yeah but back to what I'm
doing right now yeah i'm playing i'm
placing the logs yeah I'm definitely
doing that but I don't know actually I
kind of like this area usually I'm not
really a fan of overdone rock work but
this is the overdone park and everything
is over the top so might as well so that
means branches ridiculous foliage and
well incredible amounts of crunch
rubbery everywhere Graham shrubbery is
something that you should never forget
you need to place it everywhere because
basically its life and its love and oh
god damn that chestnut tree I remember
at some point in this episode i
accidentally remove that thing and then
it turned out that it was pretty much
impossible to actually get it back the
way I had it because of random tree size
shape placement or whatever the kids
have these days
and so yeah ask with that thing but I'm
pretty much going to finish this entire
part in this entire section of the
roller coaster in this episode and then
move on to other things that being the
wing rider in the next episode or in the
last episode rather because of course I
was that one person kind of mess that up
but yeah that means the full package
with this episode so the supports the
rockwork the foliage and the scenery you
get everything it's a full deal but it's
not really too much of an exciting area
I do like that tree a lot actually
though yeah I just it's kind of cliché
but it's just Kauai dear just having
that one tree in the middle the helix I
I don't know what it is but I have that
feeling it you could call it OCD you
could call it that but i think that
nearly everyone has that as soon as you
place the helix helix as soon as have
any like senior roller coaster you just
feel like now I need to put something in
the middle because you have this circle
in your pocket have this empty circle
and you're just like I need to fill it
with something it's just impossible to
leave the helix just there without
anything unless it's on the lake of
course but he'll I was so ridiculously
well yeah I was just drawn toward that
helix on the on the lake that was just
like no I'm gonna build a castle in it
so he looks on the middle of the lake
but still going to add a casa to it
because you need something in the middle
of the helix us just um somebody needs
to do like a psychological experiment on
it some some crazy naughty science guy
should do that assigned Bill Nye to do
in a to do research on roller coasters
and helixes and he'll probably find
something out that as long as you're not
six flags you just need to add something
in the middle of your helix or something
like that so I decided to go with that
chestnut tree and onto the foliage again
and this foliage is of course very
similar to the rest of the foliage of
this ride because of course I did want
that I do want the foliage to look sort
of like and just kind of mixing in some
other trees and not making everything
exactly the same because that's boring
but of course you don't want to deviate
too much from what you had previously so
that means loads of sets again
just mixing all of those goods sets
there's something that I really love
with this is that that one little tree
in station Jim's gardening 2.5 which is
a curious thing to say because I love
all of the things in station Jim's
gardening 2.5 I mean that that one
little tree that kind of looks like a
fern I don't think it's actually called
the phone but it's that kind of tree
that if you lower it it looks like a
fern more than the ferns that people
actually call ferns and it's funny
because basically we've had this game
for 24 10 years we've had let's game for
10 years and then there's been custom
scenery builders and everything they've
all built phones and then station Jim
comes along and he's like a look at my
tree and it looks like a fern more so
than all of the other previous phones
did so at least that's my opinion so
that's why I decided to span that little
trio everywhere I don't quite remember
the name Mike okay but I need to stop
that but and that thing is going to turn
into an inside joke I need it okay what
was I going to say I don't even know
anymore but yeah yeah yeah i remember in
okay so if you kind of have seen it or
if you know what kind of tree is then
that's cool i suppose but I just always
forget things doesn't matter though as
long as that thing looks good honestly
so many of the trees I don't even know
like we're with trees and flowers and
bushes in roller coaster in three it's
either I placed them and I don't know
what to call so I can't refer to them or
I actually do learn the names and then I
started seeing them in real life and I'm
like hey I know that plant and I like
showing off on my to all my friends and
boasting how that flower over there's
this in his name and it just kind i
don't know if that's a good thing to
save you if you're a boy because i'm not
really yeah that's not really the
stereotype of boys is it however i do
like flowers so whatever and yeah i'm
not even working on flowers anymore
there's the looping over there which was
a pain in the dick because of course
it's a looping one first of all it's of
course it's an inverted looping so it's
not there are no pacts which are made to
those things so of course I'm gonna feel
at it how I even started with a fill
with the supports in the beginning but
then there's that pit underneath it and
if you've worked with the roller coaster
second three enough and if you've worked
with pits and then you kind of know that
pits in roller coaster second three
especially with paths and on top of them
are a pain always they are never not a
pain especially when the flux trons did
that one pit that was like a 300 feet
deep and then wanted to put a roof on it
yeah good luck with that though I think
you succeeded in the end it's one of the
more sketchy things that were like oh
snake and three it's definitely
something that could have been kind of
fixed in terms of gameplay so yeah it's
very dodgy thing but what can you do
about it you just kind of had to work
with it oh and then I saw that little
house over there and realized they
didn't have any windows that's just me
building houses and then be like now I'm
gonna add windows later on and then
forgetting it so yeah I had to do that
otherwise I would have never done it and
now i'm placing that little tree
everywhere I think that's actually the
phone that I so adore and more trees
because for some reason I didn't do the
foliage in this area yet and when I've
done this area I think only the top area
kind of still needs foliage so i think
i'm going to do that in the next episode
so yeah pretty much finished here is so
ready to move on so see you guys in the
next episode which i'm going to do more
foliage and of course some other things
so till then